autre rencontre celle des représentants
des planétariums européen s'agit cette
fois d'astronomie mais sous l'angle de
la vulgarisation des connaissances à
strasbourg un petit record est en passe
d'être battu puisque le planétarium
fêtera bientôt son 100.000e visiteur au
bout de trois ans d'existence le
commentaire de marie claude chose
2500 élèves tous les mois au planétarium
de strasbourg lundi oui planétarium de
france l'astronomie fait désormais
partie des programmes scolaires surtout
dans les classes de 4e où elle est même
obligatoire dans les cours de physique
mais l'astronomie est encore trop
souvent perçue comme une science
réservée à une poignée de savants des
savants un peu fou comment peut-on
diffusé autrement cette science aux
élèves et aux adultes sans qu'elle soit
rébarbatives
à l'initiative de l'équipe du
planétarium de strasbourg 150
spécialistes venus de 15 pays différents
ont échangé aujourd'hui leur expérience
au conseil de l'europe
ce premier colloque des planétariums
européen a permis d'échanger des
expériences pédagogiques variées mais
aussi des inégalités technique
en effet certains planétarium sont plus
élaboré que d'autres les plus
performants ont acquis un dispositif
informatique et c'est le cas du
planétarium de strasbourg grâce à des
micro processeurs
le public peut suivre les mouvements de
plusieurs milliers d'étoilés
scintillantes et colorée la réputation
du cinéma cosmique strasbourgeois n'est
plus à faire elle a largement dépassé
les frontières bas-rhinoise bientôt le
100.000ème visiteurs haut-rhinois et
bas-rhinois ou lorrain la réponse ne
devrait pas tarder